Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to torment a virtual
armadillo, become happy, or sad depending on
which way we are bending, create a ton of jelly
sandwiches, design a crazy bridge, and more.
So, what is going on here? Well, this new paper
helps us enhance our physics simulation programs
by improving how we evaluate derivatives.
Derivatives describe how things change.
Now, of course, evaluating derivatives is not new.
It’s not even old. It is ancient. Here you see
an ancient technique for this, and it works well
most of the time…but whoa! Well, this simulation
blew up in our face, so, yes, it may work well
most of the time, but unfortunately, not here.
Now, if you are wondering what should
be happening in this scene. Here is the
reference simulation that showcases
what should have happened. Yes,
this is the famous pastime of the computer
graphics researcher, tormenting virtual
objects basically all day long. So, I hope
you are enjoying this reference simulation.
Because this is a great reference simulation.
It is as reference as a simulation can get.
Now, I hope you know what’s coming. Hold on to
your papers, because this is not the reference
simulation. What you see here is the new technique
described in this paper. Absolutely amazing.
Actually, let’s compare the two. This is the
reference simulation, for real this time,
and this is the new, complex
step finite difference method.
The two are so close that they are
essentially the same. I love it. So good.
Now, if the comparison made you hungry, of course,
we can proceed to the jelly sandwiches. Here is
the same scene simulated with a bunch of previous
techniques, and…my goodness! All of them look
different! So, which of these jelly sandwiches
is better? Well, the new technique is better,
because this is the only one that preserves volume
properly. This is the one that gets us the most
jelly. With each of the other methods, the jelly
either reacts incorrectly, or at the end of the
simulation, there is less jelly than the amount
we started with. Now, you are probably asking,
is this really possible? Yes, yes it is! What’s
more, this is not only possible, but this is a
widespread problem in physics simulation. Our
seasoned Fellow Scholars had seen this problem
in many previous episodes, for instance, here is
one with the tragedy of the disappearing bunnies.
And, preserving the volume of the simulated
materials is not only useful for jelly sandwiches.
It is also useful for doing extreme yoga. Look -
here are a bunch of previous techniques trying to
simulate this, and, what do we see? Extreme
bending, extreme bending… and more extreme
bending. Good I guess? Well, not quite! This yoga
shouldn’t be nearly as extreme as we see here. The
new technique reveals that this kind of bending
shouldn’t happen given these material properties.
And wait, here comes one of my favorites.
The new technique can also deal with this
crazy example. Look, a nice little virtual
hyperelastic material, where the bending energy
changes depending on the bending orientation,
revealing a secret. Or, two secrets, as you see,
it does not like bending to the right so much,
but bending towards the left, now we’re talking!
And, it can also help us perform
inverse design problems. For instance,
here we have a hyperelastic bridge built from
over 20 thousand parts. And here, we can design
what vibration frequencies should be
present when the wind blows at our bridge.
And here comes the coolest part - we can choose
this in advance, and then, the new technique
quickly finds the suitable geometry that
will showcase the prescribed vibration types.
It pretty much converges after 4 to 6
Newton iterations. What does that mean?
Yes, it means that the new technique
comes up with an initial guess,
and it needs to refine it only 4 to 6 times
until it comes up with an excellent solution.
So, better hyperelastic simulations,
quickly and conveniently? Yes please,
sign me up right now! And, what would you use
this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!